The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, what we're
doing today is what
I call flexology--
most of you were here
last time-- this conducted
improvisation approach.
So, we've got a music stand
here for the conductors,
if you want it.
And we've got a couple stands
here if people need anything.
But you're free to do
whatever you want, so--
AUDIENCE 1: So, I have three
different melodic lines.
Copy for you.
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
AUDIENCE 1: So, they're
labeled 3, 4, and 5,
and I'll signal those with
the appropriate number.
And then the other cues, I
listed at the bottom, so 1, 1
and 2 are from the
standard flexology sheet,
so 1 is you improvise
with a lot of notes, sort
of active playing,
2 is improvised
with a few other notes, mostly.
3 to 5 is [INAUDIBLE] by
[INAUDIBLE] the melodic line,
and then feel free to improvise
upon it once you've played it
once or twice.
If I need to change
the dynamics,
I'll indicate it sort of
hopefully intuitively,
and that's it.
I decided not to do
cue-out and cue-in.
I can just take care
of that with dynamics.
Any questions about the cues?
OK.
PROFESSOR: Then we
should try to keep
all of these about two minutes,
maybe two and 1/2 minutes.
Something like that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So, to cue you in, I'll do
a number and call you up.
OK.
So let's try.
[PLAYING FLUTE]
[FLUTE AND GUITAR PLAYING]
[PIANO, FLUTE, AND GUITAR
PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
How did that suit your--
AUDIENCE 1: The
[INAUDIBLE] are varied,
but this thing I noticed when
people began playing was when
I envisioned this in my head, I
was swinging the eighth notes,
but I didn't write
that on the cue sheet,
so you guys decided
to play it straight.
And, I didn't even
thought of listening
to the piece that way.
The other shocking thing was
hearing things be out of phase,
since I didn't really
establish a tempo,
but it still worked
out well even
when people weren't
playing together.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Very nice.
Players, any comments?
Was this clear?
Could you follow
the instructions?
Because it looked like a very
clear set-up on the page.
Very, very good to have
five things, three of them
actual lines, two of them
sort of textural things,
and we've got the
whole density thing
that we've worked with
before on a couple occasions.
So I thought that
was really good.
Really good.
And obviously, you said
you were shocked sort of.
If you did this again, you
could specify more things.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
You could specify
swing eighth notes.
AUDIENCE 1: You could-- I didn't
even think of writing that,
but I should have.
AUDIENCE 1: Right.
Well, maybe or maybe not.
AUDIENCE 1: I like the
way it turned out, anyway.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It was very nice, very musical.
And once again, we
had the situation
where, particularly, piano is
the main rhythmic instrument.
So once piano comes
in and establishes
a groove of some sort, another
concept we've talked about,
people tend to
gravitate around that.
So, if you are going to
do this a second time,
you might specify
the swing quality,
but you might also say, try
not to get into a groove.
Just as a test
case sort of thing.
Just something to work with.
Very nice.
Cool.
Who would like to go next?
OK.
PROFESSOR: Go for it.
AUDIENCE 2: All right.
So, I'm just going to
draw this on the board.
PROFESSOR: Uh-oh.
AUDIENCE 2: So, my piece
starts off with a set tempo,
so I'll sort of signal
that at the beginning.
And then the goal after
that is to slowly introduce
each of the instruments.
I guess I'm just going
to include everyone
in this, because
at the beginning
it's going to be very sparse.
Basically, I'm just going to
ask you guys to pick one note
and do any rhythm that you want
on that note, but in the tempo.
And I'll also introduce
you guys one at a time.
And them I'm going to have
two motives that are just
going to be sort of
visual, and I'm just
going to cue you guys one
or two each at a time,
and then the rest of you
guys just stay on your note
that you pick.
So basically, you have the
center note, which is the one
that you choose.
And so the first motive
will be like this.
So that's the first motive.
So this is-- And
then the second one.
So this is [? my idea. ?]
PROFESSOR: You
like the sine wave?
AUDIENCE 2: Yeah.
Sort of a mix of frequencies.
PROFESSOR: What's the top one?
AUDIENCE 2: I don't know.
AUDIENCE 1: Any indication
of how long each of those
should be?
AUDIENCE 2: No.
For the pitch.
So, this is your starting
note and then go up.
And the actual notes you
use are totally up to you.
It's all improvisation.
So, I guess I'm going to start
from this side with piano
and introduce you
guys in one at a time,
and just go with the tempo
and start a rhythm on a note
and then once we
have everyone in,
then we'll go for these motives.
So--
[PIANO PLAYING]
AUDIENCE 2: I just
want one note.
[PIANO AND TRUMPET PLAYING]
[ALL INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Composer, conductor?
AUDIENCE 2: That
one sounded cool.
I wasn't really
expecting anything,
because these are just
sort of randomly made up,
but it was interesting.
I like how it had
the sort of groove
to it in the way that
it started out with.
And I guess it would have been
nice to have some areas that
were a little more sparse.
I probably should have had
some signal sort of for people
to drop out and make
it sparser so I go back
to that rhythmic
thing, but I guess
that was just
something [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Players.
Comments from the players.
AUDIENCE 1: Everyone did
the lines differently.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE 3: You asked, right?
If you hadn't asked what
does the level of the line
represent?
Pitch.
OK.
Probably people would have
played that differently.
PROFESSOR: What did you
feel as you were playing?
What did you feel or what did
you hear as you were playing?
AUDIENCE 3: I felt like
I was taking a walk.
I mean, because you had
everyone doing their--
they had some simple walking in
place kind of thing filling out
before the lines happened.
PROFESSOR: What about in
terms of the overall sound?
The way you described is
your particular perspective.
Right?
AUDIENCE 3: Well, kind of.
I mean, it was
based on my feeling
from what everyone else
sounded like, but yeah.
It was how I felt.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And what I'm trying to get
at is, did other people
basically do that?
Because that's a
typical thing you do.
You think about
what you're doing.
And/or did you factor in playing
off of what others were doing?
Was anybody more conscious
of the second approach?
Or can't you remember?
Because it was hard to tell.
Frankly, as an
observer, it was very
nice what was being created.
But it was almost like I could
tell, as we went this way,
that each neighbor was
listening to the neighbor.
That's the easiest thing.
But I'm not sure
whether-- were people
aware of what was happening
on the piano, for instance?
And were you aware of what
was going on at the other end?
AUDIENCE 4: I could,
like, [INAUDIBLE].
It's kind of hard to make out,
because it's a [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE 3: Yeah,
I think because it
was so dense it would be hard
to hear the entire thing.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Well, these are things
we want to work towards,
and, you know,
especially, particularly,
collective improvisation.
Solo improvisation
is its own animal.
And that has peculiarities and
things that you have to know.
But collectively, which is
what we've been doing mainly,
it really is a challenge to try
to listen to the whole thing
develop as well as be
attentive to your contribution.
So let me just suggest
that, as we go forward,
we just try to pay a
little more attention
to the overall gestalt,
so to speak, as we go on.
But this was great, and what
was happening was great.
Really wonderful stuff.
And once you came in, now we
got the oboe into the mix.
So that's another--
and now we're
going to have another flute.
Good.
Now, if you can give me
a written thing of this,
that's important.
AUDIENCE 3: Oh, yeah.
I'll send it to you.
PROFESSOR: That'd be great.
OK.
Who would like to go next?
So is that a couple
of melodic fragments?
AUDIENCE 5: Ah, yep.
So I have two small
written parts, here.
And I have those--
1 and 2, I guess.
And I have these more
just to establish
a groove for then the rest of
you guys to do your thing over.
But, yeah.
As far as my hand signals
go, if I point to you
and I flash the number 1 or 2,
that's just indicating the part
you're going to play.
So this is 1, this is 2.
And, yeah.
So I'm basically going start
layering you guys in one
by one to establish this groove.
Not necessarily all of you.
Maybe just a few
to get that going.
And then, once that's started,
I have these modes, just
kind of like floozy kind
of mode, written out here.
And basically with that, if
you're not playing the groove
that I've laid down here,
what you're going to be doing
is watching for me to go
like this with my fist.
And that just means, pick
a note, any note, in here.
Just play that.
So I'm going for short
bursts or sound, I guess.
If that makes sense.
And yeah, that's basically it.
I guess also, when I'm going
like this, higher more intense,
it's going to be
a louder dynamic.
Softer and lower
is going to be--
AUDIENCE 3: How much
trouble would it
be for you to write
those on the board?
AUDIENCE 5: Actually, it
wouldn't be any trouble at all.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah, so that's just about it.
I'll write these down
so you guys can see it.
And, oh, yeah.
The only other thing is, so, if
you're not playing the groove,
if you're picking
a note in this mode
I have here, if I go
like this with my hand
and I also go like this
with my other hand, that's
to indicate pitch.
So if I were to go like
something like this,
this is indicating, pick a
note, any note you want in here,
and then as my hand goes
down, descend in pitch.
Ascend [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
Just, again, picking any note
in here, just going up or down.
All right.
Yeah.
And then when I'm having you
just pick any note you want,
it's just any in here.
All right.
Does this all kind
of make sense?
AUDIENCE 3: Is that A, B, C?
AUDIENCE 5: Ah, sorry.
It's A, C, D, E, G.
AUDIENCE 2: And the
repeat happens once?
AUDIENCE 5: Ah, the repeat
happens-- it just continues.
So every time we get there,
we just repeat it back.
Yep.
All right.
So this would be-- if
I point to you with 1,
playing you're playing top.
If 2, you're playing bottom.
AUDIENCE 1: And they
should be in concert pitch?
Right?
AUDIENCE 5: Yep.
All right.
I guess we'll start with piano.
I'll have you play 1
to start with, I guess.
All right.
1, 2, 3--
[PIANO PLAYING]
[PIANO AND GUITAR PLAYING]
[PIANO, GUITAR, AND FLUTE
PLAYING]
AUDIENCE 5: Keep going.
If I point to you, you're
going to improvise something
on your own. [INAUDIBLE].
[ALL INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So,
composer, conductor.
What did you make of it?
AUDIENCE 5: Ah, yeah.
That was cool.
I was kind of hoping to just
establish a simple groove
and then let it get more-- open
up and have fun off of that.
PROFESSOR: What was this again?
AUDIENCE 5: So, this was
supposed to be-- just,
I laid down the notes in
this floozy sounding note.
And I just wanted people
to pick any note in there
and just play it in
short bursts of sounds.
PROFESSOR: Did people get that?
AUDIENCE 1: It was
really hard to do.
AUDIENCE 5: Yeah.
AUDIENCE 1: Because
we didn't know
how many times you were
going to do this in a given--
AUDIENCE 5: Right.
Yeah.
The implementation was a
little trickier than I thought.
And also, I didn't
tell you guys how
I was going to, like,
cue you to stop playing.
But I think you caught
on well enough for that.
PROFESSOR: And also,
you didn't mention this,
did you, for the--
AUDIENCE 1: You mentioned
it during the piece.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Right.
That's all right.
AUDIENCE 5: I'm working on it.
PROFESSOR: But each of these
constructs-- it's interesting,
because you've clearly
thought it out,
which is part of a
point of the assignment.
But then it's clear
that when you enact it,
there are things that
you hadn't thought about,
which is like any laboratory
experiment, I guess.
And so, this is what you
find out by doing it.
And then the next
time-- right?--
you would factor that
kind of thing in.
But I thought it
worked really nice,
and that tune is sort of like
an African village kind of sound
that I've heard in a
number of things like this.
So it was very nice.
Very nice.
Comments from players?
Anybody's comments on that?
Great groove.
Great keeping of the groove.
Good OK.
Let's go to the next contestant.
AUDIENCE 6: Basically,
there's going
to be five gestures
that we're doing,
and they're all on your paper
and I will demonstrate them
first so that you know what they
are and they don't look weird.
So, the first thing
says, meditative.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE 6: Which we're
going to gesture by this,
maybe a little more flipping.
And it's supposed to kind
of be a cue to the scale
that Alex is
writing on the board
and the-- I guess a
throwback to the Indian music
that we sort of were exposed
to early in the semester.
PROFESSOR: Can I just ask--
this looks very Indian,
this hand signal.
AUDIENCE 6: Yeah.
I wasn't trying--
well, I was trying.
So, yeah.
So that's why that's like that.
Because it was a visual cue
and hopefully an oral one also.
AUDIENCE 5: And it's
supposed to sound
like Indian classical music?
AUDIENCE 6: Yeah.
Yes.
AUDIENCE 5: Wow.
OK.
AUDIENCE 6: So,
this improvisation's
going to be a little
more directed, obviously,
because we're going to
be in that frame of mine.
The second thing is the
hand wave, which is this.
And that means to
cycle/ undulation,
so you can do whatever you want,
but it needs to be repetitive.
Waving fingers, that's this.
It's a cascade of sound.
Do what you will
with it, as usual.
The tempo will be given by
just general conducting stuff.
If we conduct high, then we
would like you to play higher,
and if you conduct low, then
we'd like you to play lower.
So, you can take off number six.
The tempo is going to
cover tempo and the range
at the same time.
And then dynamics is like,
two hands louder, softer, shh.
Obvious stuff.
And getting cut off and whatnot.
And we're actually
going to split, I guess,
the room in half, and one of
the pianists can come with me.
Alex and Ben are both
going to conduct,
and we're going to see
how this turns out.
AUDIENCE 5: Question.
AUDIENCE 6: Yes?
AUDIENCE 5: So that's a scale?
AUDIENCE 6: That is a scale.
AUDIENCE 5: OK.
Why is there an A flat after
an A natural if it's going up?
AUDIENCE 7: I mean,
it's not a scale.
It's notes-- OK.
AUDIENCE 5: It's a
sequence of notes?
AUDIENCE 7: Yes.
It's a sequence of notes.
AUDIENCE 6: It's a power scale.
AUDIENCE 5: Is there an order
to it, or is it just a sequence?
AUDIENCE 7: No,
there's not an order.
AUDIENCE 6: Yeah.
Just play it how
you would like it.
AUDIENCE 5: OK.
AUDIENCE 6: But
these are the notes.
OK.
This is my first time
moving like this, too.
So-- OK, I'll take
Chris, I guess-
AUDIENCE 7: Yeah,
where are we splitting?
Between [? Vanita ?] and AJ?
OK.
So, you four, and then
you're taking Chris.
AUDIENCE 6: Yeah.
OK.
I guess-- I'll also bring
you guys in individually too.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Conductor, composers.
What do you make of this
which we just created?
AUDIENCE 6: It was cool.
AUDIENCE 7: It was
like two pieces.
It was awesome.
AUDIENCE 6: Yeah.
AUDIENCE 7: It was fun seeing
the two different groups
playing in the same scale,
but playing [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE 6: I completely
forgot that-- I was in my head
when I was-- when we were
thinking about splitting,
I was like, oh, I'm going to
listen to what Alex is doing.
And I completely did not.
PROFESSOR: That was
my next question.
Right.
AUDIENCE 6: Yeah.
AUDIENCE 5: You were
just having so much fun
using us like marionettes.
Like, you play this
and you play that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE 7: At first, I
was just experimenting
to see what I could
do, and then I
looked to see what she was
doing and she was doing this,
and then I was like, oh,
wait, I'll do that to.
AUDIENCE 6: That
was interesting.
PROFESSOR: That was completely
different than anything else
we've heard so far.
Very different.
Players, what are your comments?
AUDIENCE 2: I really liked it.
I think the only time--
well, I couldn't really
hear you guys all that well.
Like, I was really listening to
James on the piano and guitar.
But there was a point where
you started going like this,
and they were doing high-pitched
things, so I heard that,
and I was like, oh, I should
try and blend in to this.
So he was leading me on
a tempo a little bit,
so I sort of matched the tempo
a little bit more to that,
and it sort of sounded cool.
PROFESSOR: So you were
both watching the conductor
and gravitating to other
people, other sounds in the--
AUDIENCE 2: Yeah.
I started gravitating
over there a couple times.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE 3: I was impressed.
I mean, I'm impressed by that.
There was enough going on that
it was hard to pay attention
to anything but your
conductor out of two,
and the people maybe, like,
immediately surrounding you.
PROFESSOR: Well, I
had the advantage
of not having to play,
so I got to hear it.
It was great.
It was really-- it was
very interesting, textural.
I mean, a number of you
who have gone so far
have talked about
wanting to maybe lessen
the density at some point
or something like that,
and that happened just because
of whatever choices you made,
and then however
you folks responded.
And probably, it's
also a function
that we've now been doing
this for, what, maybe not
exactly an hour, but
maybe 40 minutes.
So we're all becoming more in
tune to what the concept is.
So, it's very, very,
very interesting.
You know, there's modern
dance groups as well as
theatrical groups
that do improvisation
and that work also with
musicians, and so you could
definitely-- you
could be the dancers.
And then people respond--
AUDIENCE 7: This
is it, right here.
PROFESSOR: --certain motion
and then back the other way
and all that kind of thing.
So, really good.
Really good.
AUDIENCE 1: The one thing
I'd maybe change next time
is some of that-- like, the
waving fingers hand motion.
When you did it, I forgot
what it was completely and had
to ignore you for the second
and read it off the sheet.
AUDIENCE 3: Also, I had no clue
whether-- I stuck to that scale
the whole time, because
I didn't know what else--
what other scale to play.
AUDIENCE 7: Yeah, and that's
what we actually intended.
We intended to start off
with that, and then people
to just generally play
that throughout all
of the [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
AUDIENCE 6: Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE 1: Cool.
Cool.
And by the way,
this-- I don't know
if you guys had
thought about this,
but this arrangement
of notes, this
could be construed as what's
called a pitch set, meaning
it's not a specific
scale, but it literally
is a collection of pitches.
And you can choose that.
It sort of comes out of 12-tone
method and that kind of thing.
And you can choose to say--
what have you got there?
You've got a
nine-member pitch set.
You could designate, play
in a straightforward way,
or take three notes
or begin to manipulate
those in different ways.
So there's a lot of things
you can do with that.
In other words, each of these
pieces we're hearing today,
you could take the basic
elements you've got
and really work on it.
You could probably
spend an hour just doing
sort of a workshop with
each of these approaches,
and then maybe do
three or four pieces.
And I'll bet each piece
would be different.
At least, that
would be the ideal.
OK.
AUDIENCE 8: So our
idea was, we're
actually going to focus more
on the rhythmic aspect of what
people are doing.
And maybe the harmony
and we'll come up
with different melodies.
So our way of giving an idea of
what the rhythm will be-- so,
let's say I'm starting
off by the tempo,
and then maybe if I want
you to play eighth notes,
I'll go, like, eighth notes.
And so then this
would mean you're
playing eighth
notes on some notes.
We decided we're going to--
AUDIENCE 3: Two per beat?
AUDIENCE 8: Yeah,
so, two per beat.
AUDIENCE 3: Two per beat.
AUDIENCE 8: Or,
like, four per beat.
AUDIENCE 3: So, nothing
slower than a quarter
note is going to happen.
AUDIENCE 8: No.
AUDIENCE 3: OK.
AUDIENCE 8: So, it's just
kind of a guide for setting up
the groove.
And then we will bring people
in and out for improv lines.
AUDIENCE 3: So, if you,
for example, hold up three,
do we have to play three notes
or can one of them be a rest?
AUDIENCE 8: Yeah.
So, yeah.
You could play, like, a triplet,
with one of them being a rest.
Yeah.
That's fine.
The idea is just to give
you an idea of the rhythm.
Or so we could set up
more complicated rhythms,
like eighth note, quarter,
quarter, eighth note,
eighth note, quarter.
AUDIENCE 3: Like, you'll have
M on N for arbitrary M on N?
Because you're going to
be pointing at each person
and putting up a
different number.
AUDIENCE 8: Yeah.
AUDIENCE 3: OK.
AUDIENCE 9: Also, so,
just to clarify, only
when you do that, it's
only for that beat rather
than a looping,
infinite all the time.
So, if it's like, two, nothing,
two-- if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE 8: Ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-ba.
AUDIENCE 3: OK.
I'm dead.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE 8: But
we never loop it.
Does that makes sense?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE 9: I guess
the way I think
about it is, it's like a
way to sort of help push
along organically
coming out collectively.
And the other thing that we
were thinking about doing
was, if we wanted to change
the pitches of the groove
at any point, we could,
like-- I say somebody,
and then the secret would
be how many half steps.
Say, two half steps.
All right, up?
Wait for it, now you shift up.
So, going down, three half
steps going down, go down.
AUDIENCE 3: Sudden shift?
Like, you go down
on a chromatic?
AUDIENCE 9: So I mean,
it'll be in time.
So you should be able to preempt
when I'm going to do that.
If that makes sense.
Oh, and also, you're
sort of encouraged
to deviate from-- play
outside the range of just,
like, one note continuously.
Obviously.
AUDIENCE 8: So we're going to
start on the D Dorian scale
and, at some point,
using the modulation,
you might modulate up or down.
AUDIENCE 3: Also, by the way--
I mean, this group's small.
We just didn't want to have
three different conductors.
We were going to do the same
thing that Tess and Alex did,
of splitting in half.
So, half is following Adrian,
half is following Vinnie,
but because we're
doing modulations,
you have to be paying attention.
[? So, if anyone ?]
wants a modulation--
AUDIENCE 8: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE 9: OK.
AUDIENCE 8: All right.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[PIANO AND SAX PLAYING]
[PIANO, SAX, AND FLUTE PLAYING]
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
AUDIENCE 8: [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
And again, completely different
from what just preceded you
and all the others.
So, you're take on what worked
and all that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE 9: It was a good way
of keeping everyone together.
I think it felt a
little [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE 8: It also felt
a little too strict.
AUDIENCE 9: It did feel strict.
I was like-- so, when
I did give people
notes and things
like that, I was
kind of hoping that there would
be more variation and stuff,
even if I said da-da-da.
And then I went
[? on to move ?] somebody else,
that they would sort
of play around with it.
But I guess maybe it was a
bit strict system in itself.
PROFESSOR: So if
you did it again,
you might build in
something about taking
a little more liberty?
AUDIENCE 8: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I thought it
was very, very interesting.
Really interesting.
And it was a rhythmic
thing, obviously,
but became a color field.
I don't know if anybody
else sensed this.
Because of the different
tambers, particularly
over here.
We have muted trumpet and
oboe, flute, obviously,
and then the strings
and the piano.
I mean, you would around, and
when you shifted sometimes,
the combination
effect-- in other words,
the relationship to whoever
else was playing, whatever other
pitch-- because
you're getting sort
of a different
version of overtones
or relationship that way.
So I thought it was
very interesting.
Do you guys know
the Terry Riley.
Piece called "In C"?
You know that?
It's very much like this.
We have a recording and Evan
Ziporyn did a version of this
not too long ago on one of
these many concerts going on
in the spring, and
it's basically--
the pitch is C, that's it.
But there's about
30-some little fragments.
Sort of like what you were
doing, but written out.
Little fragments like
da-da-da-da, da-da-da,
and then that kind of a thing.
And so you sort of
evolve a group mind,
and then you can expand it.
I think it's a variable
duration as to what happens,
but you're thinking,
in other words,
is very much in that ballpark.
So you might want
to check it out.
Just Terry Riley, like
sounds, R-I-L-E-Y, "In C."
It's very, very cool.
Very cool piece.
Very nice.
Great.
This is wonderful.
This is great variety.
This is fantastic.
Somebody else.
AUDIENCE 10: So, I actually
made a bunch of different things
possibly-- oh, sorry.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
AUDIENCE 10: --a bunch
of different things
to possibly do, including
I guess a sort of riff.
So, for the first one, the one
is rhythmic pulses in tempo,
and watch for the tempo.
So just-- you can
play notes, feel
free to switch between
two or three notes or just
a single note.
That's up to you.
Two is a lyrical legato
playing, sort of continuous.
AUDIENCE 3: Can you
write these on the board?
AUDIENCE 10: Sure.
Then I actually had a drawing.
Can everyone see that?
Does everyone got it?
So I guess I was going to
start with the piano on five.
So, yeah.
And it's up to you to interpret
the tempo of how it's played.
I just drew them
as quarter notes
because you can see
the notes that way.
So.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
Conductor, composer,
what did you feel?
AUDIENCE 10: So, I actually
had nine different things that
sort of just broke
down, and then I
guess given the atmosphere that
I've been feeling from everyone
else with the small amount, I
decided to pick a few of them
to put on the board for
everyone to look at.
Because I only made one copy.
So, I guess just this,
if anyone recognized it,
is actually-- it's the very
first part of Jimmy Page's solo
from "Stairway to Heaven."
I guess I was feeling
that yesterday.
But, yeah.
PROFESSOR: It was very nice,
and you, as all the conductors,
you're getting very expressive.
It's wonderful to see this.
I mean, you guys could be
part of a dance troupe.
I mean, we could call this
a musical dance troupe
and you could masquerade
and go out and do something
in the spring time,
you know, whatever.
But, no.
It was very, very nice.
And everybody's got their own
particular way of doing this.
It's very interesting
how that worked out.
Plus, this is the
first little thing
we've had on the board or
musical thing that's gone down.
All the others have gone up.
So, I don't know, maybe
it's the time of day,
but now we're going
with Jimmy Page.
But now we're all descending,
you know, sort of ideas.
Very nice.
Players, comments on this piece.
Everybody played-- I thought--
followed you very, very nicely.
AUDIENCE 10: Tried to
keep things pretty simple.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
A useful approach.
AUDIENCE 11: OK.
This is kind of based on a
really nasty thunderstorm,
so you can keep that in
mind while you're playing.
And the parts are
numbered 8, 9, and 10,
because I wrote a bunch of
parts but I like these the best.
So, there's going to be some
free interpretation here.
We're going to start
out with a summer day
with kind of clouds floating
sparsely was my image.
So everybody can kind of
play something pretty.
Key of F major So just
like play pretty notes
in the key of F major.
Make it kind of sparse.
And when I do this, that
means just play, like,
a really ugly high note.
Because that's like
lightning off in the storm.
The beginning of
things being ugly.
And then when I do
two, then you're
going to switch to
9 because that's
the same [? chord ?] and
just play these notes.
I kind of have two
parts, sort of.
AUDIENCE 3: Why don't you just
renumber them 1, 2, and 3?
OK.
AUDIENCE 11: I can-- whatever.
It's an order.
AUDIENCE 3: Anything
you can do to simplify
that would be appreciated.
AUDIENCE 11: OK.
I'll renumber it.
OK.
So, this is just
going to be ugly.
Play all the ugliest
notes that you can find
and the theme can
kind of be this flow.
And then I'll use this to
slow down and speed up.
So I'll eventually slow down,
and then we'll come into this
and it's like, I don't know.
It's a really destructive storm,
so it's kind of melancholy.
Yeah.
OK.
And this means start.
[WHISTLING]
AUDIENCE 11: OK.
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
So, composer, conductor, what
are your thoughts on what
happened?
AUDIENCE 11: It was a
little less organized
than I expected, which
is definitely my fault.
But it was cool.
PROFESSOR: So how
would you adjust
that in another performance?
AUDIENCE 11: I guess I would
make-- because I kind of had
the idea of having
these parts coinciding
to some extent, at
least in the beginning.
So I would probably make it
be like that at the beginning
and make more of a beat.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Oh, so have
a rhythmic structure.
AUDIENCE 11: A little bit.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Now, what's the--
because some of your notation,
there's notes occurring
simultaneously.
What was the idea behind that?
AUDIENCE 11: That was
kind of like the parts
that should occur together.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE 11: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE 11: So if
it was more rhythmic,
it would be like those occur
together, and those and these.
PROFESSOR: I liked all
the visual-- the bursts
[INAUDIBLE].
And this is almost
like an accordion sort
of an idea or something.
Yeah.
Very good.
Players.
Comments on this?
Easy to follow?
Seemed like it was, you know,
because you're directing,
I mean, you're conducting.
You're really giving
pretty specific signals.
Very nice.
Do you all know the
Beethoven's Sixth Symphony?
By now, you should know
it if you don't know it.
The middle movement is a storm.
It's a quiet day, like
you're describing,
and you even hear the sounds of
birds that whistle or whatever.
And then you hear a thunder
with a timpani coming in,
and the thunder in a storm.
And I-- one time, I was
at Tanglewood listening
to the BSO, and
they played this.
And this is an
honest-to-god true story.
As that movement came up and
the storm clouds threatened,
this huge, black,
storm cloud came over
and it started to
rain, and then it
stopped exactly as
the movement ended.
And it went on to the next.
So make of that what you will.
But it was a very interesting
experience, shall we say,
on the lawn of Tanglewood.
Maybe you're channeling
Beethoven here a little bit
or something.
AUDIENCE 3: So this piece
is called "Birthday,"
and I feel like one of
these real jazz people
because I did the following.
So, oh-- do you have some
way of standing there.
You can just take one.
There's an extra.
And so I said the following.
Let M be the number of the
month of your birthday.
And then there are things in
the parts that depend on it.
So, for example, I
was born in November.
M is 11.
And I'll say things like,
transpose this part up
in half steps.
So, we're not going
to do number 5.
Number 5 involves you
singing, and it's really hard
to sing in key together.
So instead, we're
going to do just--
so I have numbers 1, 2, 3 and 4.
They're the four, let's say,
phrases of the happy birthday
song.
And they're in whatever key is
appropriate to your birthday
month.
I'll cue them with just
numbers 1, 2, 3, 4.
And it, again, cues that
apply to individual people--
or, like, if I want to
cue a group of people,
I'll do like this and then
I'll say number 2 or whatever.
And, keep in mind,
you'll be playing
in different keys,
which is good.
And I don't want you
to play simultaneously.
I want you to play somewhat
chaotically out of sync.
So the cues are-- OK, so.
Number.
Self-explanatory.
It's on the sheet.
Another cue I'll have is this.
This doesn't mean do
a shake or anything.
This means play chaotically.
This means play something
that isn't written down
that sounds crazy.
Shake hands equals chaos.
And then the other thing
that I'll do is this.
So, this does not mean
play the same note.
This means play, well-- it
means play a sustained note,
and then a couple
seconds later, change it
to some other sustained note,
approximately at random.
It should be
So level hand motion means play
a series of sustained notes.
And the last gesture I'll use
is the flexology chord gesture,
where I do this.
Where I, like, sweep
my hand back and forth.
It means play a chord.
Together.
OK.
So, that's what I got.
Sound good?
Any questions or any comments?
I guess I'll cue you in.
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: I didn't
know what you
were going to do at the end.
I didn't know if you
were getting ready to--
AUDIENCE 3: I was thinking
about doing something else,
but I figured no
one would follow
because they assumed I was done.
PROFESSOR: Very nice.
So, your impressions
of how this all worked.
AUDIENCE 3: That
was pretty hard.
I knew it would be hard
to be clear in front
of different people.
It was.
Also, no one ended
up doing-- I cued
a bunch of people for number 3.
I didn't, I think, hear
anyone doing the alternative.
So I have cases.
If M is even, you
play, you know,
(SINGING) happy birthday
dear-- something.
And then if M is odd,
you'd go the other way.
I can't even do this.
(SINGING) Happy
birthday to whatever.
Something like that.
That would've been cool.
PROFESSOR: So in
another iteration,
and then we're going
to have to move on,
in another iteration
people would actually
have to sort of study
this a little bit more.
Because I saw Brian,
you were cued 2,
and you were looking
to see what's 2.
Because we're getting a
lot of material very fast
this afternoon.
But you would do just
like you practice
for a piece that's written out.
You would really have to
know what the cues were.
AUDIENCE 3: I guess I was
hoping that the familiarity
with this melody would help.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE 3: It probably did.
But still, it's a lot.
PROFESSOR: It was there
in the background.
OK, so two more.
AUDIENCE 13: So there's six
new reference material that'll
just be basic framework material
that I tried to at least
transcribe to the order
of numbers in [INAUDIBLE].
So these first two are just
these very simple patterns.
Definitely not
very strict, or not
required to be very
to the transcription.
But just as a starting
point for the improvisation.
And so I would maybe take
that with ones or twos.
And then the rest are
graphical notations,
so three is kind of
like a trio above.
It's the same thing for
the rest of these patters.
Five and six have
their own patterns,
so interpret those as you will.
So those will just be
the number signals,
and if I point at you
or point at a section,
use those numbers,
that's probably
what you'll want to do.
And then some other signals
that I was interested in using
is this.
Bringing hands together
like using a [INAUDIBLE]
would be like making
what you're doing simpler
or adding more space
to what you're using.
Where the opposite
like this would
be making it more complicated.
I'll just do some very
intuitive, dynamic markings,
too.
And yeah.
Anything else should
be fairly intuitive.
So is everyone good with that?
[PIANO PLAYING]
[PIANO AND SAX PLAYING]
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Nice.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So, as far as this
coming up, let me just ask.
What worked as you had
envisioned it and were there
any surprises in here?
AUDIENCE 13: So, I think it
was a good-- it kind of got
everyone started in at
least some idea of what
sound or some rough
idea of key, I guess.
It was maybe a little
freer than I expected,
just because everyone
started at different tempos.
Yeah.
So it was also
different adding--
I guess it was probably not
necessarily a bug, but just
a feature of how it works.
People have different, I guess,
ideas of how to add complexity.
PROFESSOR: Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Good.
Very nice.
AUDIENCE 14: So, I didn't
write any material.
So this is going to be focused
on listening to other people.
All right.
So, one is active.
Two is sparse.
These are the ones
we've used before.
What we're going to start
with is three, which is,
you should be alternating
between serene chords
and motives.
As by motives I just
mean two to four notes.
It can have rhythm if you want.
Something that can be
easily recognizable.
OK, so hands rising is
crescendo, diminuendo.
And if I cup my ears, that
means listen to other people
and try to repeat their motives.
If I do a ball, like
this, this means
that we're going to
try to sort of all come
into-- all repeat
the same motive.
Like coalesce into one.
And if that happens,
then I'll go like this,
and that'll mean to
gradually break apart.
So, we'll see if that works.
All right.
So.
You guys--
[MANY INSTRUMENTS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: What did
you feel about this?
AUDIENCE 14: Well,
it didn't really
coalesce as I was
expecting it to,
maybe because there wasn't
a really distinctive motive.
But I did hear some
feedback, which was great.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I heard that
as the non-interested observer,
or very interested but
non-participating observer,
I should say.
I could definitely
hear that happening.
AUDIENCE 14: Yeah.
I was trying to bring
out certain motives,
but I guess one really
became dominant.
PROFESSOR: There, again,
literally practicing
or working with the material.
AUDIENCE 14: Right.
But really, really well done.
Give everybody a hand.
Give yourself all a hand.
Very well done.
So, as I've said after
each person's thing,
I've said-- or
almost everybody--
I've said composer and/or
conductor or composer,
conductor, because
each of you, when
you did that, you're
both those things.
You're enacting out
of-- essentially,
this is your raw material,
whatever it would be,
for each person.
And you're enacting
in the moment
through improvisation what the
composition is going to be.
Because as we've
said, improvisation
is composition and all that.
So this is just a different,
yet another way to do it.
It's a little bit different
than what we've done before,
but can be interesting.
I would suggest that
you think about--
whether it ever
happens again or not.
I mean, it could be factored
into your final project,
obviously-- think about what
I've said to a couple of you.
If you were to do your piece for
today, if you were to do that
again, what would
you do to enhance it?
What could you do
to make sure that it
was closer to what
your intention was?
And the other thing
is, I think you
might want to check out
that OCW film of Walter
Thompson, his sound-painting
thing from another course.
But I think if you just
put in Walter Thompson
and sound painting on
OCW, you'll get this.
It's fascinating, what he does.
And he has a whole
different set of signals.
I think you'd get
a kick out of it.
What was the last thing
I was going to say?
Oh, yeah.
See you Saturday.
Thank you.
Good job.
Really good job.